hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the cat games now this
game is apparently adorable and all
about cats and I am so ready to relax
Oh doh oh oh oh my god
oh it's so good oh is this supposed to
be a password oh what a great picture oh
it's awesome oh my god
these cats are so talented where's the
porn where's the tab a porn on here this
doesn't seem right these are all actual
sports weightlifting
Patman volleyball Messick's soccer high
jump relay and field hockey come back to
you why bath back up okay to get back oh
you almost bapt it Oh y'all sit okay so
under the cat games we go what the hell
is this why am I looking at the goddamn
couch why I don't even know why this
exists this game is amazing in every way
it's amazing and I love it please do
racing welcome to indoor racing do you
want to start the tutorial yeah sure I
want to know what I'm doing look at me
go oh it's a slippery linoleum Oh
running into small obstacles which were
lying on the ground make you lose
control oh so stealthy look at that
underwear look at that wine ow
[Music]
oh so cute I love this game
my god give it a try
this wants me to run in oh boy okay then
you get ten points for each rubber ducky
collect Oh flags ducks okay I got you
waking the sleeping dog Platt bumping
into a bouquet to 20 points watch out we
lose control for a month
oh so it's a risk/reward tank take that
you stupid dog
oh they look like little chicas if you
crash into furniture it's game over
[Music]
skull that's it thanks for listening
okay alright then I'm ready let's do
this let's do this let's do this hell
yeah okay I don't know what I'm trying
to do here man there's a lot more
obstacles I thought okay alright then
I'm not a very good cat but I like that
cat but painting that's a good yeah I
did [ __ ] okay let's try again shall we
oh the cute cat bottom oh my god oh I'm
ready okay this time I'm not gonna suck
dog that was apparently my first brush
scooch Oh scooch it dude
Oh scooch kitty weenie oh my god I
wonder if I'm able to slide on this
perfectly sure buddy map freaking dick
okay yeah you're gonna go for the flags
more than I'm gonna go for that
sugar milk about pepper but oh my god
it's so cute this game is my life now
this game is ever all well broke my
spine oh my god it better
oh my God look at the little cat in the
corner oh it's so cute oh this game is
perfect in every way
oh I love it this gate was $2.00 I'm not
advertising it or anything it's $2
infinite enjoyment right swim challenge
Oh
bagging time you want to start the
tutorial yeah okay click on the yellow
toys yellow toys oh well squeak squawk
yes click on the pink toys yes they're
hard again
a right click oh I got a right click on
the pink ones both times the blue ones
got it I am so talented let him I am hit
you for demonstration okay okay oh I get
it
if it's coming towards my head then I
should probably hit it because it's
gonna be bad so I'm gonna let it hit got
a regain Oh watch out for the shower
click the shower while it vibrates so
you get 50 points okay that sounds nice
okay with your paw oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh yes Oh coordination is my name
[Music]
all things considered
oh I'm so good at this oh my god I'm the
best cat that ever lived cat person not
a dog person somebody have to tell chica
about that she's not in the room right
now
[Music]
Oh get rekt i score uh [ __ ] vibrato not
me
Oh mommy mommy mommy hey but I did good
I got pretty good on the vibrating
shower I'd say that's a pretty good
Gambian score yeah this is a lot less
rage-inducing than a lot of these games
that I play before rage-inducing
oh one last left cap read billiards I'm
ready
show me what welcome to capri billiards
yeah I'll start it yeah okay let's do
this you'll get asked three questions it
doesn't seem like the billiards I know
cap Reed will be shown in the play field
Turkish Angora don't know what these cat
breeds are you must get the ball showing
in the correct with the cat breed okay
okay I gotta get correct ball into a
hole which sounds dirty and it probably
is but I'm gonna do my best here first
ball holes correct one one hole will be
marked you get ten points for each other
cat in the hole watch out for these
balls one of them it's okay little guy
I'll do my best here
I'll make you proud of me bap get
wrapped I guess maybe it's like an
educational experience do because I
don't know what the answers are nope
that was not it okay so I know that one
the wider one is a Turkish but maybe
you flip meant to do it meant to do it
meant to do that okay point no buy [ __ ]
that oh damn boink Go Go baby good not
the white one go baby go
nice not correct though no I am Dom I
couldn't have gotten worse love [ __ ] I
don't know they are I come on man I
don't know
Cornish red hat Rex Rex I'm gonna assume
it's the line front yeah one of those
not doing too good
nope not that one okay come on come on
not that one okay boink nope still not
bro you know my odds are not doing well
for me you think I would have gotten
this by now but the answer is absolutely
not frickin dick nope not that one okay
I guess man I was trying to go for that
one but it was on the end anyway how can
I done that the answer is I could add a
Vanna Brown well this narrows it down so
it could only be a few of these intimate
choices damn it
I'm gonna go for that brown one oh I'm
going for this one brown first
boink lamp not it but I knew that cuz it
had to be this brown one at the bottom
here that didn't work okay
physics got a little slow there for a
second it had to think about it thought
I got that good I did good I did real
good
oh my god oh he's sleeping down oh oh oh
my god you're so cute
okay enough of that
outing cats are trying to sleep bring it
away that's all the time I have for the
cat games and this is adorable and
interesting so if you guys have a
solution to this puzzle here let me know
down in the comments below I might just
solve it on my own time here
oh wait wait no they have letters on
their jackets so four is g3 is i7 is o
so it's e ah okay I got this en en en
igen igen igen igen igen igen igen igen
igen e e n IG n e n IG n e quick en i GM
n e know he an IgM and IgG
ye o w he an IgM e o w enigma Wow oh I
got an achievement yeah hey I did it
okay I solved it it wasn't our heart if
you think about it real close but either
way that is the cat gifts let me know
what you figure this down the comments
below and I'll provide a link to the
game to itself case you want to indulge
us so thank you everybody again and as
always how soon
in the next video
[Music]